beleza tão bom pensar lá no começo da
nossa educação como são crianças onde
começa a colocar nossos filhos na escola
com os coleguinhas para trabalhar em
conjunto a aprender socializar colocamos
depois no ensino fundamental
começamos a separar disciplinas matérias
professores diferentes no ensino médio
mesma coisa mais professores mais
disciplinas aquele modelo de educar para
cobrar fazer uma cobrança uma prova uma
avaliação quem a maioria das escolas
aqui no brasil e no mundo inteiro e do
quanto essa madeira educa o aluno
decorar e cobrar será que realmente um
para pensar dois segundos será que
realmente é esse formato que os alunos
aprendem será que é assim que eu aprendi
será que é assim que eu ensino cada
pessoa aqui nessa sala provavelmente
aprende de uma forma diferente eu você e
todo mundo nesse teatro aprende
diferente então não faz sentido se todo
mundo aprende de uma forma diferente eu
ensinar igual ensinar da mesma maneira
para todo mundo e seu ensino igual
geralmente o cobre igual eu cobro da
mesma maneira para todo mundo se ninguém
aprende igual muito menos vai ser
avaliado na mesma maneira como todo
mundo como um todo e essa questão é
importante por ser a quem não está
limitando a capacidade dos alunos de
pensar só que está permitindo que alguns
pensem e 9 faça diferente é quem está
criando alunos e pessoas para ser maus
nobel maiores inventores para resolver
realmente problemas nossa humanidade
está limitando a capacidade de pensar e
de estudar tem caminhos pra fazer isso
como é que eu vou então educar uma turma
de 30 40 50 alunos na forma diferente
tem alguns exemplos no mundo inteiro têm
algumas escolas que com muito então é
muito mérito consegue fazer um pouquinho
diferente são poucas infelizmente não
conseguem então mudar esse formato
educação professores diretores não está
envolvida nesse processo de cassação
consegue pensar diferente e fazer uma
educação diferenciada
infelizmente eles são poucos porque
principalmente precisa mudar a cabeça do
professor
o professor precisa parar de pensar que
ele é o centro de educação os educação
tem se o aluno a educação tem que ser
centrada no aluno
é um mediador é o instale para apoiar e
fazer com que o aluno realmente aprenda
a sentir aquele estereótipo professor
que estava na frente e sabe tudo a gente
tem muito acesso à informação hoje em
dia é muito mais fácil o aluno traz
novos conhecimentos e professor auxiliar
ele nesse formato
quero trazer para vocês um exemplo é que
a gente faz na faculdade mas antes essa
história começa um pouco antes com dois
professores e professor newton professor
silvio não estavam não era das pecinhas
quebrados nós quebra-cabeça não estavam
contentes como de educação tradicional
tudo era mais interessante que os alunos
celular redes sociais tudo era mais
interessante do que realmente estudar e
aprender e eles começaram a pensar em
desenvolver esse modelo de educação
diferenciada
então essas imagens aqui vocês olharem
não pra ter um pouco de conhecimento que
a gente faz mas principalmente para
dizer que eu tô cansado de ver em
diversas palestras aquela foto tinha
escola anos 1990 escola 2018 olha só é
igual não faz diferença o meio ambiente
eu posso ter um ambiente igualzinho
tinham 190 fazer uma aula diferenciada e
do caminho uma forma diferente claro um
ambiente bonitinho com o pufe com cores
nas paredes
talvez ajude também estimule mais meu
aluno mas não é só isso faz a diferença
é o professor comprometido é escola que
realmente queira fazer diferente aquele
formato de educação
nasce então a nossa chamada escola
sistêmica
rossi também foi adotada um curso
superior de análise momento sistemas é
que dura três anos e desde o começo a
gente já pensou em fazer um formato
educação diferenciado é ensino superior
têm diversas regulamentações normativas
que o mec exige então tem preocupar
muito com isso fazer da forma certa
a escola sistema por exemplo a gente
entendeu é que se cada pessoa aprende
diferente
eu não posso mais ter que ao tradicional
do professor lá na frente com um
projetor com quadro com giz e não
consigo mais é conseguido cá 41 da mesma
maneira
desta vez o autor adicional talvez dois
três quatro ou cinco alunos iriam
realmente aprender e os 32 e os 40
alunos que estão ali eles não iriam
aprender ante abril no nosso modelo
educação as aulas tradicionais
só que a gente cria um problema bom som
tem mais ao tradicional como é que é
como é que o ensino 40 alunos a nova
solução foi trazer mais professores na
sala de aula em nossas turmas que têm
três às vezes quatro professores
professores com capacidades diferentes e
complementares que eu possa juntar
conhecimentos diversos para apoiar pague
aos alunos nesse formato e educação e
para auxiliar os professores que estão
no dia a dia a gente criou o ritmo e
trilhas de conhecimento essas fitas e
conhecimento são um delineador da
espinha dorsal do curso o aluno vai
realmente aprender
ele não é um limitador como consegue ter
mais conhecimentos fora daqui mas é um
caminho para seguir como está trilhando
a sua jornada de nossos professores não
vai fazer essa parte de guiar esse aluno
nesse processo é e aí a gente tem muito
problema ensino superior de evasão você
ter uma idéia no brasil 25 por cento é
uma taxa de evasão aceitável em curso e
até 50% e evasão
essa invasão muito muito a parte disso
diz respeito ao não conseguir
identificar e vivenciar para que serve a
quem está aprendendo ele estudou alguma
coisa e não consegue ver na prática para
que aquilo serve para que ele vai
aplicar de um futuro trabalho em um
outro ambiente então para evitar esse
tipo de problema a gente criou duas
estratégias
a primeira estratégia é de nivelamento
com o nosso curso é para desenvolver um
software muitos alunos já vendi curso
técnico trabalha em empresas que têm
conhecimento de um de uma área da
programação não faz sentido esse aluno
que já conhece estudar as disciplinas os
mesmos conteúdos aquilo que não conhece
nada pode fazer uma avaliação e consegue
posicionar esse aluno que já tem
conhecimento um ponto mais pra frente da
sua época sua escala de conhecimentos
que vai desenvolver durante um curso
também consegue colocar o aluno no ponto
certo que ele precisa aprender isso nos
motiva ele vai aprender coisas novas e
consequentemente vai se desenvolver
muito melhor o nosso sonho é conseguir
formar esse aluno mais cedo nem menos
tempo mas provavelmente a gente não
consegue e qualquer vantagem então desse
aluno que já tem conhecimento
consegui aprender muito mais um modelo
tradicional para eles que ia tá limitar
os conhecimentos que temos é na matriz
curricular nesse formato e consegue
fazer com que ele aprenda muito mais
escuro novas tecnologias e isso também
muito por causa daquele professor que
não está fixo registado naquele modelo
que só ele tem o conhecimento
e aquele aluno que não têm tanto
conhecimento que iniciou do zero começou
a prender programação desenvolvida em
software do zero e vai ser acompanhada
guiado pelas trilhas e conhecimento dos
professores com as pessoas que estão ao
redor para auxiliar ele nesse processo
de educação e aí a responsabilidade da
educação e fator de motivação é do aluno
o desenvolvimento a velocidade de
crescimento dele vai ter menos força e
velocidade o trabalho que vai ter para
realmente desenvolver e aprender
a segunda estratégia é um aprendizado
não está associado à prática de trás um
problema pelo aluno e para ele resolver
aquele problema ele precisa aprender os
conhecimentos então ele só vai aprender
um determinado conhecimento quando
precisa realmente aplicar aquilo para
resolver determinado problema é achar a
solução para aquilo isso garante que ele
consiga relacionar a teoria com a
prática e fazer se eu explicar para
vocês como é que se amarrar o cadarço
hoje aqui você não praticarem não
fizerem isso na prática
quando cheguei em casa e vamos esquecer
porque não conseguiram relacionar a
teoria com a prática bom nessa etapa do
curso ele está mais ou menos no segundo
é um curso de três anos e está no 2º e
3º ano a gente entende que até aqui
ele foi mais ou menos guiado direcionar
nossos conhecimentos dos professores
estavam apoiando nesse essa etapa do
curso a gente tem que estar apto a voar
com as próprias asas se consegue então
fazer e tomar suas decisões como a gente
fazia isso é um projeto consolidado e se
consolidar e traz uma empresa com um
projeto real com um problema empresa
chega até nós com um problema e nós
alunos vão ser capazes de resolver esse
problema
esse projeto obrigatoriamente em equipe
também conseguiu juntar vários alunos
trabalhar habilidades que tinham de soft
skills né relacionamento com pessoas
gestão de tempo gestão de prazo
conflitos mas trazem ambiente é muito
próximo da nossa realidade da empresa
que vai atuar ou já atua nas estradas
com as regras complementares e além
disso conseguem ter essa capacidade dele
e atrás da melhor solução
muitas vezes utilizam tecnologias
pessoas não conhecem as pessoas estão
aptos a direcionar e apoiar ele no que
for preciso ele vai buscar novas
tecnologias novas soluções e realmente
resolver o problema que foi proposto a
ele lá no começo
é do projeto consolidado e isso esse
formato de de projeto consolidado todos
falar de curso permite que meu aluno do
início ao fim tenha currículo diferentes
provavelmente nenhum aluno que entrou no
primeiro semestre e se formou no último
tem um currículo igual cada um tem suas
dificuldades suas trilhas e
conhecimentos e desenvolver os seus
projectos que ele fez então cada
currículo nossos alunos vai ser
diferenciado e isso é reconhecido pelas
empresas no mercado trabalho a gente vê
o feedback a gente tem de empresas que
não são contratados depois que eles são
muito rápidos e muito bem preparados
para atuar no mercado de trabalho por
essa diversidade por esse formato de
educação sem falar claro naquilo que não
tinha nenhum conhecimento talvez teria
evadido curso não consegue fazer com que
ele realmente aprenda e se forme em três
anos
bom isto é muito bonito aqui falando
para vocês é lindo e maravilhoso mas na
prática tem que ter muito esforço
dedicação aos professores em sala de
aula 234 às vezes tem que falar
trabalhando todo dia pra conseguir
ajudar e auxiliar os alunos a resolver
esses problemas a gente não sabe a gente
não vai conseguir mudar a educação no
brasil educação básica não chegam até
nós como português e recitaram
matemáticas de ser deficitária um pouco
a cultura e pouca história a gente sabe
que nossa parte precisão superior nessa
área específica está atuando a gente
está fazendo a nossa parte eu fico feliz
e outras a minha paz nós professores em
sala de aula o dia fazendo a parte deles
e eu pergunto pra vocês se vocês faz
alunos professores se você está fazendo
a parte de vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]